I've told that you love dirty jokes I do  like dirty jokes is surprising me I  shouldn't say that because that probably  comes across just like sexist or  something but but it it surprises me  that you would like really dirty jokes  what kind of kid do you remember a dirty  joke that you could tell us that you  really like okay I just want you to know  I'm a FEMINIST but I'm still going to  tell you this joke okay  there are these two sperm and they're  swimming and they're swimming and  they're swimming in the one sperm so to  the other sperm I'm so tired have we  reached the uterus yet and the other  sperm says the uterus we haven't even  reached the esophagus  [Laughter]  [Applause]  my defense is that I don't get it  you